our car tester sasha is looking at the
mercedes c-class today under the beating
portuguese heat
he's seeing how the c63s amg fares on
the racetrack
the new c63s model is sporty and dynamic
like all cars made by mercedes high
performance amg division its speed and
handling make it perfect for a day at
the track
375 kilowatts of power mean the c63s can
hit 100 kilometers per hour in just four
seconds it comes at a price of just over
84 000 euros in germany
race driver ben schneider says it's a
car for all occasions
it's a car that you can drive on normal
streets for day-to-day use he says but
one that also feels at home on a
racetrack that also likes how drivers
can program the car with their own
individual setup to suit their needs
they can even have different setups for
different race tracks whether drivers
want comfort or need to handle wet
conditions they can choose their setup
and that makes this car stand out
the car's design is typically sporty for
an amg
the front of the car is marked with two
power domes and all the way to the back
the car's form shows it's all about
speed and strength
everything about the c63s shows that
this car is not to be messed with
sasha can't believe how quickly the c63
takes corners here on the racetrack but
it's not a cheap car the basic model
costs 76 000 euros and a few thousand on
top of that for the s version and
drivers have to consider whether it's
worth taking it out on the racetrack
with the risk of not seeing a corner
properly and then taking it too
as well
the standard c63 model is no less brutal
than the s version both have impressive
handling and both are fun to drive
that's thanks to the amg ride control
handling system with electronically
regulated shock absorbers and a rear
axle limited slip differential
the car's interior is just as sporty as
the outside
from the three-spoke steering wheel with
large paddles for manual shifts to the
finish of the surfaces
and there's a full program of comfort
and security systems available to the
driver
the c63 amg is powered by a 4-liter v8
bi-turbo engine
that gives it some serious beef under
the hood
it consumes about 8.2 liters of gas over
100 kilometers on average
all in all the car isn't cheap at over
75 000 euros but for that you get a car
that will get you to your destination
quickly and safely
sasha says even the standard model is
fun to drive out on the street with 350
kilowatts of power the s version packs
more of a punch but it also costs more
and because he had so much fun earlier
sasha's heading back to the racetrack
thousands
the volkswagen tiguan has been around
the block a few times now the compact
suv's been around since 2007
its name a combination of the german
words for tiger and iguana was chosen
back then by the readers of a car
magazine
the tiguan has always cut a dynamic
figure but it's changed over time since
2011 it has featured angled headlights
it's practical too plastic cladding
protects the bodywork from mud for
driving over muddy terrain
back to that name what does it really
mean
artistic einhold explains it's a cross
between a tiger and an iguana the tiger
of course being the deadly predator
native to asia and the iguana the
camouflage specialist of north and south
america and germany though the tigawan
is the king of the compact suvs it's
competing with the toyota rave 4 the kia
sportage and the ford cougar the most
remarkable feature of the tiguan is that
it's inconspicuous maybe that's why
germans love it the 125 kilowatt engine
is also great for off-road driving
the 2-liter turbo diesel engine produces
320 newton meters of torque through
1750 revolutions per minute the
all-wheel drive system delivers plenty
of power split between the two axles by
a haldex clutch
all of that means the car is secure as
can be out on the road but it also
consumes more gas on the front wheel
drive version and the model we're
testing has a top speed of about 190
kilometers per hour
says although the tigawan can go
off-road it's also great on the street
that's no surprise given its
similarities to two other vw models the
passat and the golf and anyone who's
ever ridden in a volkswagen before will
feel at home in this car it stands out
from the competition with its adaptive
chassis which allows drivers to go for a
ride that focuses on speed or comfort
with the comfort setting giving
passengers a particularly smooth
experience
adding to that experience are these
special seats which come as standard
there's plenty of space in the back too
practicality comes to the four here as
well
there's a fold-out table and the seats
can be put away to make more storage
room
whether on the streets or off-road the
tiguan is an all-rounder that suits all
conditions
can see why the tigawan leads the market
for compact suvs it doesn't have any
weaknesses and meets volkswagen's high
standards for quality and performance
but at 25 000 euros it doesn't come
cheap the all-wheel drive 4motion model
is more expensive at 29 000 euros
more varieties are due to be released
soon as well as a larger seven seater
and a coupe version to compete with
bmw's x-series the american suv market
is especially important for volkswagen
none of their models feature in the top
20 most popular cars in that class
the new additions will freshen the
series up but the tigawan already has
everything it needs to justify its place
at the top of the compact suv market
aside from its drivability features it
also boasts great safety standards it
was awarded five stars by the car safety
program euro end cap
peugeot will release a new edition of
its 208 super mini in june
alongside the new improved pure tech and
blue hdi engines the french company will
give customers the chance to personalize
their cars both inside and out
the new 208 will be available in 13
different colors
including the eye-catching orange power
and the more understated matte finishes
ice gray and ice silver
the mazda mx-5 has represented freedom
and driving pleasure to car owners for
more than a quarter of a century and now
the japanese company is presenting the
fourth generation of its two-cedar
roadster
the bonnet is flatter while the
windscreen frame has been slimmed down
and shifted back and it's up to 100
kilograms lighter than its predecessor
specially coordinated skyactiv-g direct
petrol injection engines power the car
and continue 25 years of driving
tradition
some sounds are so wonderful that you
just can't get enough of them like the
roar of the bmw x6 m's eight cylinder
high performance engine
bmw's constantly says that after the
success of the first generation of which
they sold almost 20 000 units in five
years it was time to bring out a second
even better generation under the hood
you'll find the latest generation m2m
powered turbo engines with 4.4 liters of
cubic capacity and 8 cylinders
it boasts 575 horsepower 20 more than
the previous generation and 750 newton
meters of torque that's 70 more than
before
the car flies from zero to 100
kilometers an hour in just 4.2 seconds a
full half second less than its
predecessor pre says that's true sports
car level
that's impressive considering that this
car is 4.9 meters long and has a hefty
curb weight of 2.27 tons bmw says
average fuel consumption is 11.1 liters
per 100 kilometers so it's a bit of a
gas guzzler but then the x6m doesn't aim
to be an eco-friendly model it's a car
that combines extremes and pushes
boundaries
carson pre says they've made lots of
modifications to the chassis and
drivetrain to make the car more agile
precise and rid of some characteristics
typical of sports activity vehicles so
the vehicle doesn't understeer its
performance is very neutral he believes
the x6m unites all the precision and
predictability you'd expect from an m
model
like its breathtaking sound the other
sporty details suit the x6m well in
particular its coupe like silhouette
transforms it into a premium sports
activity vehicle or sav
side gills with air breathers reduce
turbulence in the front wheel arches
at the back a rear spoiler helps lessen
aerodynamic lift and drag
from behind the new x6m also looks more
dynamic and pleasing than the standard
version
carson says that with the new x6m bmw
once again aims to appeal to
performance-oriented people
with a car of this class they can
express that more than they might
ordinarily
he feels that this makes a very strong
statement about people their performance
orientation and their taste in design
inside everywhere you look the x6m is a
little more luxurious a little sportier
a little more extravagant
to achieve optimal acceleration from a
standing start the driver activates the
launch control function which has been
adapted from race cars drivers depress
the brake pedal while stomping on the
gas until they reach the ideal starting
rpms
once the driver takes his foot off the
brake the car shoots forward as fast as
possible
carson free says the new bmw x6m will be
sold worldwide but they expect the main
markets to be the u.s china russia the
middle east canada and germany
it's sound looks and performance are out
of this world but hearing that the x6m
starting price is almost 118 000 euros
in germany is enough to bring most
buyers back to earth fast
the nissan micra also badged as the
march has been a popular choice for
buyers around the globe for over three
decades
to date some six million have been sold
making the super mini one of nissan's
top three car models so the renault
subsidiary is pinning its hopes on the
new micra to help it stay in the black
our car tester tanju gang says the mikra
used to be a real woman's car cute and
cuddly now in its fourth generation it
yearns to be a global car and pleased
people from thailand to mexico tanshu
feels that in doing so it sacrificed
some of its charm
but with its curves this little runabout
is still an eye-catcher and popular with
the ladies and like their predecessors
fourth generation micros are all
four-door models and therefore more
practical
tanju says the mikra's engine range has
shrunk no diesels are on offer but
there's a 1.2 liter three cylinder
gasoline powered model which comes in 59
kilowatt and 72 kilowatt versions he's
testing the 72 kilowatt one
a supercharger helps the little engine
generate the additional 13 kilowatts of
output but does greater power also mean
greater fuel consumption not here the
more powerful engine actually uses 0.7
liters less gas per 100 kilometers so
it's too bad that it's only available
with more deluxe trim levels like the
acenta which costs upwards of 15 870
euros in germany
isn't a huge car so it's a bit cramped
in the back but he notes that in a super
mini you can't expect much space
the equipment in the micra's interior is
pretty basic
after the dashboard display greets the
driver it helps him or her save gas by
displaying the current fuel mileage
optional extras include a sat nav for
750 euros and automatic climate control
for 400 euros
the seats are slightly hard and don't
offer any lateral support but the trunk
boasts enough cargo volume to meet the
average person's daily needs
our tester says the base model micro
with the vizia first trim level which
costs around eleven and a half thousand
euros in germany is basically fine but
to get an audio system and a manually
operated climate control unit you'll
have to cough up 1500 euros more he
thinks that's a lot as the same package
in the smart 4-4 costs 1100 euros and
the climate control is automatic
but otherwise the nissan micra has
everything as super mini should thanks
to its lightweight construction it's
thrifty and agile
it offers good visibility yet is small
enough to make its way through the
narrowest of alleys so it's likely that
in future the number of microbuyers will
surpass the six million mark but the vw
polo and opal corsa still outdo the
nissan micra for workmanship
the 911 turbo made its debut at the
paris motor show in 1974.
it started out with a 260 horsepower
engine but in 1977 the car got a power
boost
thanks to its new inter cooling system
the 3.3 liter motor could generate 300
horsepower
kustov says the 911 turbo is more than
just a car it's the stuff of legend in
the 1970s and 80s there was no getting
away from it whether you were a yuppie
or a technical freak a grandma or a kid
this car polarized people kristoff adds
they either loved it or hated it coveted
it or vilified it but it certainly
didn't leave them cold
as the world's first turbocharged series
production supercar the porsche 911
turbo combined power with luxury
originally designed as a race car some
last minute changes to the regulations
robbed it of its chances on the track
but not to be daunted porsche switched
gears and turned the vehicle into a
luxury sports car though it retained one
race car characteristic
it's turbo lag christoph says rally
driver valtteroara once described it
this way you step on the gas and for a
few seconds nothing happens then
suddenly it feels like you've been
rear-ended christoph says that's true
and provides a demonstration
this baby really flies he says it's
enough to strike fear into the hearts of
the italians at lamborghini and ferrari
when it made its debut the 911 turbo
cost close to 66 000 deutsche marks 20
000 more than the priciest 911 carrera
still thanks to its stunning looks and
superior performance by 1989 over 21 000
of the original turbo models had been
sold
zero to 100 kilometers an hour in 5.5
seconds and a top speed of 260
kilometers an hour that's what kristoff
calls performance but he warns
inexperienced drivers to beware if they
hit the gas at the wrong moment and then
the turbocharger kicks in the rear end
could spin out of curves even porsha
knew the 911 turbo was hard to handle
it's a real sports car and requires
concentration to drive this commercial
states but it rewards you with a high
level of safety and driving pleasure
those who equate driving pleasure with
great acceleration and power will find
few cars to match the original 911 turbo
even today
what a beast christoph says noting that
the 911 turbo's trademark rear spoilers
are hard to overlook when the car was
introduced many owners of regular 911s
had these whale tails added to their
vehicles christoph says this didn't
escape the attention of the designers at
porsche and they eventually offered this
turbo look for regular 911s complete
with tail fin fender extensions and
fatter fox wheels
christoph finds that all a bit
embarrassing though
the design of the 911 turbo turned out
to be a hit though it was born of
necessity the wing extensions are from
the carrera 3.0 rs with slight
modifications and a porsche designer
gave the body a final going over outside
of regular work hours due to the firm's
limited budget his reward was a bottle
of whiskey
the interior incorporated all of the
optional extras porsche had to offer
however the huge intercooler for the 3.3
liter engine only arrived at the end of
1977.
the original 911 turbo wasn't lacking
for anything kristoff says but the 3.3
liter model came with even more extras
power windows power seats power sunroof
but such luxury didn't come cheap in
1974 the turbo cost over 65 000 euros a
third more than the most powerful
naturally aspirated porsche of the day
the carrera 2.7 even though it's
incredibly powerful kristoff says the
turbo is more of a gran turismo than
race car and that sports cars
enthusiasts prefer naturally aspirated
porsches
that's because the turbo only gets to
flex its impressive muscle on
straightaways every naturally aspirated
911 delivers more precise and smooth
handling when taking curves still the
turbo help porsche attract a new type of
customer
christoph says the 911 turbo was the
first and most successful turbocharged
supercar its arrival put porsche on a
par with italian supercar makers like
lamborghini and ferrari compared to
other supercars kristoff believes the
turbo strikes the right balance between
sportiness and practicality between the
racetrack and the supermarket for that
reason he feels the 911 turbo is truly a
milestone in automotive history
and a legendary car model to boot little
wonder as three decades after it was
introduced the turbocharged 911 still
packs a real punch
my
you